aussi longtemps que je me souvienne, c'est mon
ambition de devenir un olympien Eddie tu
n'es pas un athlète j'avais juste besoin de trouver
un sport en sautant
le temps de commencer à sauter quand tu as
cinq ou six ans j'ai entendu dire que tu étais un champion
alors je l'étais  pensant peut-être que tu peux me donner
quelques conseils abandonner il y en a un pour
plus haut que ce à quoi je m'attendais
tu n'abandonneras pas est-ce
que je vais le faire je sais ce que c'est que d'
être chevauché je peux t'avoir Marge
qui va faire mal  comme l'enfer votre honte
pour le sport bien
n'ai-je pas le droit de représenter mon
pays l'association olympique britannique
essaie de m'arrêter je dois le faire je
presse tout le bois pour entendre votre histoire
j'ai été expulsé de chaque équipe où est
tout le monde Lloyd beaucoup  comment faire mes preuves
Je prends le saut très au sérieux presque
autant que de prouver que les gens ont tort
j'ai plus d'esprit que n'importe quel autre sauteur
bonjour
vous préparez le mal
je